walk in this video playing against play
way cool okay oh well I have completely
forgot stuff like that before yeah let's
play let's play a French rather player
slightly slightly a tricky position in
the French then some theoretical stuff
that I don't know at all okay um what
about this this idea night coming to to
c4 and it's not really reacted to it at
all um is there some drawback with like
g5 I don't know come on let's let's do
this I'm going to play badly anyway at
the moment so i might as well play quick
this is this is for example as a
questionable maybe what I did inviting
the Knight to c3 yeah
f5 year f5 coming ha it already looks
very dangerous yeah I move like g6
cannot really be good maybe I can can
block like this d 5 Bishop c5 maybe this
is still bearable okay so at least I'm
not blown away immediately it seems okay
this does not look very dangerous maybe
I'm oops ought to see doing hmm I don't
know King edge one can go much further
than this 95 so let's get rid of this
now maybe just 95 and blocking d5 and
placing the night on a good square queen
is six or d6 maybe just d6f for in the
mix yeah yeah I can just take this why
not okay yeah that's that's very nice
for black disposition but still how do i
how do I get get to the pawn rook da
terms even possible
hmm ok Queen Queen D five disruptive
foyer I'm I'm overlooking one mover cm
and of course
so I just blundered this pawn great how
do i get b 5 maybe b5 rugby 5 Bishop a
six and here I'm keeping the beep horn
and I can go rook c8 c5 maybe that's
also weakness on c3 and maybe I'm still
okay here yeah that's very strange all
that a5 is just very bad I mean he keeps
a five as an exposed porn that's just a
weakness for nothing okay like here for
example a five is hanging he taking is
what much better okay now he tries to to
do some some crazy stuff on the King
rook edge for that's not nothing with
you that's not really working of Queen
g7
no it's neither sir at the moment pretty
much dominated the only purpose of this
piece would be a sacrifice on age 50 or
f5 and this might might be on some
somehow at least if I'm somewhat term
I'm making some mistake
not sure what is hard to anticipate a
move here Luke age for Queen g7 is
pretty yeah probably not leading to much
night h 5s maybe his IDM right go here I
can I have this Queen takes d4 idea okay
maybe here again attacking I need to be
quickly of course download time
okay it's got this chick over here jack
so still the rook is a ticket here I
morning maybe some counter-attacking
move this isn't that something rook c8
maybe I can take the seven actually
that's funny isn't that some way to
encounter a check here ah come on I
cannot even play rook c8 here
unbelievable
come on I cannot believe I'm lost here
isn't this isn't this totally crazy I
don't estancia move him oh man let's
stop at the moment
the end it's not like my opponents are
doing anything great I'm just killing
myself all the time now six seconds
great now let's I cannot survive this
with five seconds and the position is of
course not not good
yeah one second one second check black
fourth hits on I can take on f7 know
that it's it's it's really a really a
tough tough time at the moon okay man
yeah Quincy three isn't the best it
seems ruki eight wins wins already
promised he's full of weaknesses he
would lose them all and the only chance
is some some hair Mary attack on my king
which is not going to work against good
defense but okay rookie age is now minus
3 and here rookie one check is solving
the issue very clearly yeah I don't I
don't really see any moves at the moment
ok this is also winning but ok I
couldn't I couldn't finish him off age
six wins outright oh come on it's really
tough at the moment ah I don't see a
single tactical move I mean even this
kind of kindergarten stuff wins the
night yeah it just winds the night for
nothing and he M lost of course yeah I
know he was in analyzing this